et
maintenant voici mon cdd tom villa
bonsoir à tous tout le monde est venu en
coupe ce soir al ahmad le rang mais sa
fiancée s'est classé voit les moyens il
ya catherine qui va venir ces mots
rhinocéros loi la [ __ ] de bonne
ambiance non premier invité thierry se
voit déjà tellement peu la semaine qui
sont obligés de venir en cours à la télé
c'est jean jacques bourdin et animations
jacques voilà le matinalier drm c'est
depuis 16 ans voilà vous présentez
bourdin direct 16 ans la jean jacques
bourdin pour marine le pen c'est un peu
son jacques martin il l'a connue toute
petite et l'a vu grandir voilà c'est
l'homme qui interroge les politiques un
peu à la manière d'un commissaire des
stups s'il manque plus que la longue
dans la gueule écoute bottin derrière la
tête c'est à bourdin qui utilisaient ces
questions un peu cache un peu piège vous
les faites plus d'ailleurs c'est dommage
vous aviez posé la question olivier
besancenot combien font à 9 x 8 et il
avait refusé de vous répondre pourtant
la réponse est facile c'est le nombre de
communistes qui restent en france
petite question jean jacques bourdin
jean jacques bourdin quelle est la
fréquence de mcr vernon dans l'eure
aucune idée
alors aucune idée c'est vrai la france
veut savoir je sais je ne sais pas
j'assume et basse et 103 points comme à
paris anne nivat bonsoir
carrière j'adore ce portrait de mon mari
que tout le monde s'évertue à faire et
qui sont totalement faux c'est quoi la
danse à ben je vous dirai pas la vérité
avec à la trouver vous êtes ensemble
depuis 13 ans au nom depuis deux minutes
depuis c'est lé bien des formes depuis
14 ans 14 ans 14
14 ans et je me rends compte qu'ils ont
jamais pris le petit déjeuner ensemble
c'est donc pour vous faire rêver c'est
pas la tour d'argent c'est la brio
le volume d'heures si c'était toi
milhamont cyber
dimanche 10 mai fois les soeurs
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il n'a quand même pas dit le principal
en ce qui me concerne c'est que ma
fonction c'est pas être femme de jean
genet en battant
pour tous les autres il va dire oui
d'abord oui le dresseur
on va en parler oui mais enfin ça peut
se dire aussi
comment on fait ben vous refaites
déconner il l'a dit pour tout le monde
sauf pour moi moi j'ai il n'a pas dit
pourquoi j'étais là je suis grand père
on a tous des plans car ils ont mis tous
les immigrés du même côté on n'a pas ça
attends rapide comme rappelé tom
niva et là c'est la fin du monde et
la seule chose a pas dit un seul et j'ai
pas envie de nous que la merde je me
mets à la place des téléspectateurs il
entend ça au début de l'émission c'est
clair bon vous avez intérêt à rigoler
si vous le faites bien
c'est bien parce que moi tu as dit que
j'étais moche et le stockage
si tu le fais croire que
non mais anne nivat vous vous venez pas
ce que vous avez écrit un livre aussi
qui s'appelle dans quelle france on vit
j'aimerais ça fait très bien quel
éditeur métier c'est d'aller voir sur le
terrain bien sûr mais non vous allez
faire un tour de france j'ai regardé
vous avez choisi de visiter civile
montluçon laval evreux lons le saunier
lent et pour finir ajaccio mais à part
ça je suis reporter de guerre mais bien
sûr ça aurait ajaccio bien sûr
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu